[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصادي الليله معكم عبد القادر
عياط في الوقت الذي احدثك فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
نبداها بهذه الصور التي نتابعها من البيت
الابيض حيث اعلنت واشنطن فرض عقوبات على
اطراف النزاع في السودان والسبب تقول
الخارجيه الامريكيه انتهاكها بروده اتفاق
جده وعرقله وصول المساعدات الانسانيه
ثم الى الخرطوم الى السودان وتحديدا جنوب
الخرطوم مع استمرار الاشتباكات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع في مواقع عده
ثم الى
عاصمه التي شهدت اليوم قمه لدول المجموعه
السياسيه الاوروبيه شارك فيها نحو 50 رئيس
دوله وحكومه لبحث الحرب في اوكرانيا
والتوتر في كوسوفو وقضايا اخرى
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
السعوديه والولايات المتحده تعلنان في
بيان مشترك تعليق مباحثات جدا البيت
الابيض يعلن فرض عقوبات على اطراف تتهمها
واشنطن بممارسه العنف في السودان
يتحدث في حوار خاص مع الجزيره خلال الحصاد
عن اسباب فرض العقوبات الامريكيه
وسفير السودان في واشنطن يتحدث حصريا
للجزيره عن موقف المجلس السيادي من الخطوه
الامريكيه
بايدن يقول ان واشنطن لا تسعى الى الصراع
مع بيجين رغم استمرار التنافس معها ويعلن
تعزيز الامن الامريكي في منطقه المحيطين
الهندي والهادئ الخارجيه الصينيه تحتج على
توقيع الاداره الامريكيه اتفاقات تجاريه
مع تايوان وتقول ان التعاون العسكري
الامريكي الياباني يجب الا يضر باي طرف
موسكو تعلن احباط ما سمته محاوله اوكرانيه
لغزو حدودها الجنوبيه الغربيه
للقضاء على نظام كياب وفي قمه اوروبيه في
مولدوفيا يطالب بتسريع انضمام بلاده
[تصفيق]
الصرب يواصلون احتجاجاتهم في شمال كوسوفو
وتصاعد الضغط الدبلوماسي على
بانتخابات جديده في بلديه كوسوفو واشنطن
تحث صربيا وكوسوفو على خفض تصعيد فورا
قائد قوات حفظ السلام التابعه
في حوار مع الجزيره من خطوره التصعيد اذا
لم يتم التفاوض والتواصل الى حل
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا قد ناقشنا معكم اعلانا واشنطن
فرض عقوبات على اطراف النزاع في السودان
في اول عقوبات تفرض بموجب امر تنفيذي وقعه
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الشهر الماضي
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي ما هي
السيناريوهات المحتمله للاوضاع بعد
العقوبات
الامريكيه وجاءت النتيجه على النحو التالي
نحو 10% قالوا ان حده المعارك ستتراجع
بينما راى نحو 42% ان الامور تتجه نحو
مزيد من التصعيد الميداني واخيرا صوت نحو
48% بالقول ان الازمه ستراوح مكانها
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
ولقائنا من نشاط الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
يتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
وكذلك دوليا
[موسيقى]
اذا اعلنت الولايات المتحده والسعوديه
تعليق محادثات جدا بشان السودان بصفتهما
راعيه المفاوضات وقال بيان للسفاره
الامريكيه ان الخرطوم ان قرار واشنطن
والرياض ياتي نتيجه الانتهاكات الجسيمه
المتكرره لوقف اطلاق النار قصير الامد
وتمديد وقف اطلاق النار من قبل القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع
وقال البيان ان الطرفين ارتكب انتهاكات
خطيره لوقف اطلاق النار شملت احتلال منازل
مدنيه وشركات خاصه ومبان عامه ومستشفيات
وضربات جويه ومدفعيه كما اثرت هذه
الانتهاكات بشكل مباشر على جهود المساعدات
الانسانيه واكد البيان ان راعيي المفاوضات
ابلغ الطرفين بالخطوات التي
سيتعين عليهما اتخاذها لاثبات التزامهما
الجاد بمحادثات جده وبشكل خاص اجراءات
بناء الثقه
هذا وكاله الاداره الامريكيه اعلنت فرض
عقوبات جديده وقيودا على التاشيرات بحق ما
وصفته بالاطراف التي تمارس العنف في
السودان وقال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انه
تم فرض عقوبات على شركه الجنيد لتعدين
الذهب التابعه لقوات الدعم السريع وشركه
للتجاره العامه التي تستخدمها قوه الدعم
السريع لشراء معدات لقواتها وشركه سودان
ماستر تكنولوجي التي تسيطر عليها الحكومه
السودانيه لدورها في دعم شركات انتاج
اسلحه ومركبات للجيش حسب تعبير بلينكن
هذا وقال مصدر المطلع في الجيش السوداني
للجزيره ان العقوبات الامريكيه لا تؤثر
كثيرا على مقدرات الجيش السوداني كون
الجيش يقوم بتصنيع ما يحتاجه داخل البلاد
كما قال المصدر ان العقوبات الامريكيه
مؤثره بشكل كبير على ما سماه ميليشيا
الدعم السريع كونها تستهدف الامبراطوريه
الماليه لاسره حميد حسب تعبير المصدر نفسه
في المقابل قال مصدر المطلع بقوات الدعم
السريع للجزيره ان العقوبات الامريكيه
تستهدف الضغط على الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع لتقديم تنازلات
متابعه لهذا الملف من البيت الابيض معنا
مراسله الجزيره وجد وقفي من امدرمان مدير
مكتب الجزيره المسلمي الكباشي وينضم الينا
من الرياض مراسل الجزيره بدر اربعان ابدا
معك وقفي عن ملابسات هذا القرار الامريكي
والتفاعلاته حتى الان في واشنطن
نعم طبعا هذا القرار ياتي بعد نحو ثلاثه
اسابيع من
منح الرئيس بايدن وزاره الخارجيه وزاره
الخزانه وكذلك الخارجيه الامريكيه التفويض
اللازم لفرض هذه العقوبات وقد رات
المسؤولون الامريكيون بان هذا الوقت قد
حان لفرض هذه العقوبات ذلك لان الطرفين
بحسب الاداره الامريكيه لم يلتزم
بمفاوضات او مباحثات جده ولا باعلان جده
وكذلك الارتكابهما انتهاكات جسيمه بحسب
مقاله مسؤول امريكي رفيع في مجلس الامن
القومي من قم من هذه الانتهاكات بحسب ما
عدد
نهب مستودعات الادويه مواصله القتال
المسلح عدم احترام وقف اتفاق وقف اطلاق
النار نهب المستشفيات
واغتصاب النساء بحسب المسؤول الامريكي
ولذلك رات الاداره الامريكيه بان كلا
الطرفين يقومان بمثل هذه الاعمال العقوبات
التي تم فرضها على شركتين على علاقه بقوات
الدعم السريع واحداهما مقر احديهما في
الامارات وشركتين
مرتبطتين بالقوات المسلحه السودانيه تحاول
الاداره الامريكيه من خلالها
منع وصول الموارد الماليه عبد القادر
كلا الطرفين خلال هذا القتال المسلح
والمسؤولون الامريكيون يؤكدون ان الاداره
الامريكيه تعمل حالا على حاليا على
مستويين المستوى الاول هو ضمان
الامتثال التام للعقوبات التي تم فرضها
اليوم والتي تشمل ايضا افرادا رات الاداره
الامريكيه بانهم يعيقون الالتزام بالهدنه
والاستقرار في السودان والمستوى الثاني من
العمل الحالي اداره الامريكيه يتضمن
محاوله التوصل الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار
مسلمه لماذا انت تفاعلات هذا القرار سواء
ميدانيا او ردود الفعل حوله في الخرطوم
نعم عبد القادر لا تزال ردود الفعل
ليست بحجم هذا القرار ليس اكثر مما قال
قالت مصادر مطلعه في الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع للجزيره ان الاول في الجيش
السوداني يقول انه لم يتاثر الجيش بهذا
القرار بينما يرى الدعم السريع انه محاوله
ضغط على الطرفين ليقدما التنازلات وهو
كذلك محاوله الضغط على الطرفين ليقدمات
تنازلات ولكن في اي مجال هذا التنازلات
هذه التنازلات وكيف القرار شمل شركات
للدعم السريع خاصه شركه الجنيد وهي الشركه
الاساسيه التي قام على اكتافها
الامبراطوريه الماليه للدعم السريع وهي
امبراطوريه عريضه وواسعه الغنى والثراء
وكذلك شركه اخرى في دبي هي شركه وهي
الشركه التي صنفت بانها تدعم الدعم السريع
تقنيات مختلفه وانها دعمت الدعم السريع
بالف سياره دفع رباعي وهي السيارات التي
تستخدم في الحرب اما على صعيد
العقوبات التي توضع على شركات التصنيع
الحربي التصنيع الدفاع السوداني
فلا ليس لها تاثير لان هذا اصلا نشا هذا
التصنيع في ظل عقوبات امريكيه متطاوله في
نهايه التسعينات من القرن الماضي نشا هذا
التصنيع الحربي وتاسس والزهره وتطور في ظل
هذه العقوبات فهو يملك كثير من الخبرات في
مواجهه هذه العقوبات ولذلك ليس مقدرا ربما
ان يتاثر بهذه العقوبات اما العقوبات على
الافراد في في المجال المؤسسي المجال
الجيش السوداني وهو مؤسسه لا تتاثر كثيرا
بالافراد الافراد يذهبون ويتحركون ولكن
المؤسسه باقيه ولذلك لا يتصور ان يكون له
اثر على الافراد وكذلك اما في مجال
العقوبات على الافراد في ان الدعم السريع
يبدو انه مؤسسه اسريه ولذلك يمكن ان يكون
الاثر عليه اكبر في هذه العقوبات
العقوبات تضمنت اسقاط العقوبات او تصويب
هذه العقوبات على من اسمتهم بعض قيادي
النظام السابق وهي محاوله من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لتقول او لمحاوله لتقول
ان هنالك ربط ما بين ما يجري الان في
الحرب التي تدور في الخرطوم
وقاده النظام السابق وهو امر لا غير منظور
الان للكثيرين الان المعركه التي يراها
الكثيرون انها معرفه داخل المنظومه
العسكريه الجيش يصنفها ويعرفها بانها تمرد
داخل المنظومه العسكريه بينما الدعم
السريع يقول انه يواجه حاله من الانقلاب
اذا هي عقوبات اقتصاديه وهنا اسال بدر
ربيعان في الرياض وايضا استتبعت بتعليق
لهذه المحادثات من طرفين الراعيين لهذه
المحادثات الرياض وكذلك واشنطن ايضا ماذا
عن الملابسات بعد هذا القرار
نعم عبد القادر من الموضح ان المسيران
لاتفاقيه الهدنه الجانب السعودي والامريكي
وصل الى قناعه بعدم اكتمال الظروف
المساعده لطرف النزاع الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع على تثبيت هذه الهدنه
وان الاحداث على ارض النزاع لم تكن
متوائمه مع الوعود التي قدمها وفد
المباحثات في مدينه جده لذلك يفهم من
البيان الذي اصدرته الخارجيه السعوديه
المشترك مع جانب الامريكيه انه تم تعليق
هذه المباحثات حتى تتضح جديه الاطراف
بالامتثال لوقف اطلاق النار ومن ثم يمكن
العوده لاستئناف النقاش وهذه المباحثات
التمهيديه كما ذكر البيان هذا البيان
المشترك ياتي عقب قرار الجيش السوداني
الذي اعلن عنه اولا من امس تعليق مشاركته
المباحثات التي كانت تجري مع الدعم السريع
والانسحاب ايضا من التعهدات التي قدمها في
البعثات والهجره الاخيره التي تم تمديدها
لخمسه ايام اضافيه البيان الصادر قبل قليل
اشار الى ان الانتهاكات اضطرت بالمدنيين
والشعب السوداني اعاقه ايضا وصول
المساعدات الانسانيه وعوده الخدمات
الاساسيه في انحاء متعدده من السودان ايضا
حتى الطرفين على الالتزام بجديه في وقف
اطلاق النار ودعم الجهود الانسانيه لتخفيف
هذا النزاع واثاره على الجانب المدني هناك
حقيقه كان هناك حرص من الرعاه على
الاستمرار هذه المباحثات وبقاء الوفدين
على الاقل للوصول الى ارضيه من التفاهمات
المشتركه لكن من الواضح انه ما يحدث على
الارض والهدنه الهشه كمثيلاتها السابقه
دفع السعوديون والامريكيون لتعليق هذه
المباحثات الجاريه حتى تتضح الامور على
ميدان النزاع العسكري في السودان بدر
ربيعان من الرياض ووجد وقفي من واشنطن
والمسلم الكباشي من الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا
لكم
ايضا متابعه لهذا الملف وتطورات ينضم
الينا من واشنطن
مستشار المبعوث الامريكي السابق الى
السودان ومسؤول لشؤون افريقيا السابق في
البيت
الابيض سيد هيدسون اذا واشنطن تقول بان
هذا الاجراء هذه العقوبات هي لتيسير ودعم
العمل الدبلوماسي فيما يتعلق بتيسير
المحادثات بين الطرفين والدفع بها الى
الامام هل تراها خطوه في هذا الاتجاه
فاعله
لا اعتقدوا انها ستكون فعاله في تغيير
وجهه نظر الاطراف المتحاربه او منعها من
شراء او استيراد الاسلحه والذخائر التي
يحتاجونها لاستمرار في القتال اكثر ما
يحصل في السودان هو ياتي من الخارجي ياتي
عن طريق اساليب
غير واضحه نعرف ان تلك الشركات الان تحاول
ان تغير اساء اساميها وعلاماتها التجاريه
وتغسل الاموال وبالتالي العقوبات هي جزء
طويل من تاريخ السودان وبالتاكيد ان
الهيئات العسكريه في السودان هي مهيئه
بشكل كافي من لكي تحاول ترتفع على هذه
العقوبات بالتالي انا لا اعتقد ان هذه
العقوبات التي تم الان الحديث عنها وفرضها
بعد سته اسابيع من بدء الصراع يبدو وكانها
اطلاق تحذيريه
من اجل محاوله لتغيير نهايه لهذا الصراع
او نتيجته غير فاعله حتى وان كان هناك
ترويع من قبل وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
بالقول ان هذه العقوبات قد تطال قادت
الطرفين اي بالاسماء السيد البرهان وحميتي
انها
ستشملهم اعتقد انه كان هنالك حديث عن هذا
الامر وهم بالواضح انه اختاروا اهدافا اقل
مستوى اعتقد ان هنالك انه على الرغم من
توقفي
المحادثاته في الجده اعتقد ان هنالك
اعتقاد في واشنطن انه سيكون هنالك تسويه
مرتفعه وضيه وان لن يظهر ايا من الطرفان
في المفاوضات اذا ما تم فرض عقوبات عليها
بالتالي من غير المحتمل اننا سنرى
القيادات العليا من كلا الطرفين يتم فرض
عقوبات عليهم على رغم من انه يجب ان يتم
ذلك لان واشنطن تحتاجهم ان يكونوا حاضرين
في المحادثات المستقبليه وهم لن ياتوا الى
تلك المحادثه يذهبوا اليها اذا ما تم فرض
عقوبات عليهم منا واشنطن مستشار المبعوث
الامريكيه السابق الى السودان ومسؤول شؤون
افريقيا السابق للبيت الابيض شكرا جزيلا
لك لاستقبل ضيفي الان من جده الدكتور خالد
بتر في الاكادي مي والمحلل السياسي اهلا
بك دكتور خالد عن هذه الخطوه الاخيره
تعليق المحادثات من الطرفين واشتراط ان
يلتزم الطرفان حتى يتم العوده الى
المحادثات كيف وجدت هذه الخطوه خطوه
التعليق وتاثيرها على الطرفين
انا اعتقد انها جرس انذار لانه لا يمكن ان
تبقى هذه المفاوضات الى الابد وخاصه اذا
لم يكن هناك نتيجه ملموسه يعني في
الحوثيين بقي يتفاوضوا في الكويت في ثلاثه
اشهر وفي النهايه رفض التوقيع على اتفاقيه
السلام في عمان ايضا
استمروا اسابيع واحيانا اشهر فهناك من
يريد احيانا يماطل ويكسب الوقت وما عندما
يخسره هو ضيف عزيز في بلد كريم ويستطيع ان
ان يبقى الى الابد لكن هذا لا يمكن لان
هناك دماء تسيل وهناك يعني مدن تدمر وهناك
اثار وتداعيات خطيره لهذا التاجيل والممار
لكنهم في النهايه اتوقع انهم سيعودون الى
طاوله المباحثات ربما اكثر جديه
وعلما بان هناك
عقوبات ملزمه وه [__] مراقبه جديه لاعدائهم
على الارض هناك من يرى في ان هذه العقوبات
حتى الان لن تكون ذات تاثير بحيث تدفع الى
طرفين من تغيير سلوكي ما حسب وجهه النظر
الاطراف الراعيه لهذه المحادثه وبالتالي
ماذا ان استمر وضعه على حاله
لا اتفق مع هذه النظره لانه على المدى
القصير ربما ليس لها تاثير هناك ما زال
مخزون سلاح موجود ما زالت الاموال باليد
موجوده ولكن لنتذكر ان كلا الطرفين له هدف
في النهايه وهو الوصول الى السلطه وهو
الوصول الى المال وهو وصول الى القدره على
اداره البلد
وبهذه العقوبات يفقد كل هذه الاحداث
مهما قاتل فانه يقاتل على مستقبل او على
رهان خاسر
العقوبات على شركه على الشركه التعدين
والشركه
الاخرى تريد اوف في في دبي يعني ان كل
تحويشه العمر التي جمعها حميد
ستتبخر اليوم ولن يعود هناك مصدر للثروه
ومصدر للقوه في المرحله القادمه فاذا كان
هدفه فقط ان ينتصر في الايام
سيستمر اما اذا كان هدفه ان يعيشه
واسرته وقبيلته ومن معه في المرحله في
المرحله القادمه
بالتاكيد سيجد ان هذا جرس انذار قوي
ومستقبل مظلم له ونفس الشيء بالنسبه
للافراد او الجهات
النافذه في الجيش والتي تظن انها
بالاستمرار يمكن ان تثبت اقدامها في
السلطه سيعرفون انهم ان هذا لن يحصل لان
المجتمع الدولي سيبطلهم ولن يكون لهم مكان
على الطاوله في المرحله القادمه شكرا لك
الدكتور خالد بطرفي الاكاديمي والمحلل
السياسي كنت معي من جده
اذا اعلنت الاداره الامريكيه فرضا عقوبات
جديده وقيودا على التاشيرات بحق ما وصفته
بالاطراف التي تمارس العنف في السودان في
المقابل قال مصدر في الجيش السوداني
للجزيره ان العقوبات الامريكيه لا تؤثر
كثيرا على مقدرات الجيش
لم يتغير المشهد في السودان منذ شهر ونصف
يتواصل القتال بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
الشارع ويتبادلان الاتهامات والتهديدات
عبر وسائل الاعلام
المتغير الوحيد في المشهد السوداني خارج
الحدود بعد ان اعربت جميع الاطراف
الاقليميه والدوليه عن قلقها من مسار
الازمه في البلاد تتحرك الولايات المتحده
باجراءات فعليه عقوبات تشمل اشخاصا وشركات
في الطرفين يقول مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي ان العقوبات تهدف الى محاسبه
المسؤولين عن تقويض السلام والامن
والاستقرار في السودان يعلن وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي عن هذه العقوبات ويقول ان واشنطن
مستعده للمزيد حتى اسكات البنادق
تشمل العقوبات الاقتصاديه وحظر التاشيرات
مسؤولين من الجيش والدعم السريع وقاده
بنظام البشير اهم المستهدفين في العقوبات
الاقتصاديه شركات تزود الطرفين بالسلاح
والمعدات ابرزها شركه تريدف للتجاره
العامه التي تتخذ من الامارات مقرا لها
بالاضافه الى شركه الجنيد لتعدين الذهب
التابعه للدعم السريع عندما ياتي الحديث
عن الذهب يحضر اهتمام قوات الدعم السريع
بالملف تقول التقارير ان القوات التي
يقودها حميد تيتو تسيطر على معظم مناجم
الذهب في البلاد ولها زبائن كثر ابرزهم
روسيا من روسيا جاء مقاتلون من شركه
فاجنور الامنيه الخاصه لحمايه مناجم الذهب
في السودان اكثر من مره سياسيا يبحث وزير
الخارجيه الروسي مع نظيره السعودي سبلت
الوصول الى تسويه النزاع في السودان
ترى مديره الاستخبارات الامريكيه ان
الطرفي الصراعي يسعين الى الدعم الخارجي
رؤيه امريكيه بعد ايام قليله من اعلان
الرئيس بايدن امرا تنفيذيا يوسع من سلطات
ادارته في اصدار عقوبات ضد مسؤولين في
السودان تلك عقوبات كان اخر عهد
السودانيين بها عام 2016 لا يتراجع القلق
الافريقي مع تاكيد على ضروره الالتزام
بخطه الاتحاد الافريقي للحل في ظل كل هذا
القناه التحركات تتوقف مباحثات جده
بانسحاب الجيش بعد عده جولات هناك عقد
الطرفين عده هدى وصفت معظمها بالهشه وسقطت
برصاص المتقاتلين ذلك قتال دفع بمئات
الالاف المغادره البلاد او النزوح عن
منازلهم كما ادى الى انهيار المنظومه
الصحيه مع شلل اصاب عمل المنظمات الدوليه
في بلد كان اخر شيء ينتظره ازمه كالتي
تدور الان
معنى منا واشنطن السفير السوداني لدى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه محمد عبد الله
ادريس اهلا بك السفير محمد لنبدا بموقفكم
بهذا القرار الامريكي بهذه العقوبات
يا مرحب شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه الموقف
نحن نرصد من حيث المبدا المنطقه العقوبات
العقوبات سلاح مسموم وجرب قبل تناوات في
السودان وفي غير السودان هو سلاح مسموم
يعني يؤثر على الشعوب
ودمر عدد من الشعوب في للاسف في المنطقه
العربيه
والمنطقه الاسلاميه فنحن نرفض منطقه
العقوبات نفسه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يقال لها يعني في في في مفاوضات جده انها
مسهل يعني فالمسهل مهمته التسهيل فباي
منطقه يعني يفرض المسهل عقوبات على على
الاطراف هل ابدا رايتم مسهلا نحمل قربان
لا ابدا نحن الحكومه السودانيه تعرف
مسؤولياتها ولكن
مؤسسات لها ارتباط عسكري
المؤسسات هذه مؤسسه الصناعات العسكريه
والسودان ماستر بتكنولوجي هذه مؤسسات
تابعه للدوله مؤسسات ليست مسجله باسم
افراد او مجموعه افراد او او فرد بعينه
هذه المؤسسات شانها شان وزاره التربيه
والتعليم شانها شان وزاره الزراعه
السودانيه هي مؤسسات مملوكه للشعب
السوداني بفرض عقوبات على هذه المؤسسات
يعني ان الحكومه الامريكيه تفرض عقوبات عن
الشعب السوداني هذا هو المنطق هذا
المؤسسات هناك تلويح سيد محمد السفير محمد
هناك تلويح صريح من قبل وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي بان العقوبات قد تطال من وصفهم
بالزعماء ما تعليقكم
نحن سمعنا ذلك وسمعنا قبل يعني قبل هذا
اليوم ايضا سمعنا
بما قالوا السيد وزير خارجيه امريكا
العقوبات يا اخي
سفره الذي لا يلتزم بتن
ما تعهد به الحكومه السودانيه الجيش
السوداني وقع على الهدنه في جده ويلتزم
تماما ما وقع عليه ان كانت هنالك عقوبات
فالكفرض على الطرف الذي لا يلتزم بتنفيذ
ما وقع عليه اما الجيش السوداني ينفذ حتى
تعليق نحن نقول لا نقول انه
الحكومه السودانيه او الجيش السوداني خرج
من المفاوضات جده انما علق هذه المفاوضات
بشروط ما هي هذه الشروط هي نفس الشروط
التي يقولها الجانب الامريكي الالتزام
بتنفيذ ما تم التوقيع عليه نحن نقول
الحكومه الجيش السوداني يلتزم بتنفيذ ما
وقع عليه انظر على الذي احتل المستشفيات
من الذي يحتل المشاكل المواطنين من الذي
يمنع من اصول الخدمات الى الى مستحقيها من
المواطنين
محمد عن موقفكم من قرار الميسرين اي
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الامريكيه تعليق
المحادثات او تيسير المحادثات في جده ايضا
ما تعليقكم على هذه الخطوه
نحن تعليق نحن تعليقنا على هذا
يا ايها المسهلان يعني نود ان نرى التزاما
من كل الاطراف يعني عمليه الهدنه عمليه
استثمار النار طريق ذو اتجاهين فلا يمكن
انا
كطرف كحكومه سودانيه التزم والطرف الاخر
لا يلتزم عندما تفرض العقوبات تفرض على
الطرفين اي منطق هذا
طيب وبالتالي ماذا عن الخطوات المنتظره من
قبلكم حيال هذه الخطوات
الحكومه السودانيه والشعب السوداني كله
كله حريص على ان تتوقف اعمال العنف حريص
على ان يرجع المواطنين الى مساكنهم حريصه
الحكومه السودانيه على ان تؤاس ستواصل
المؤسسات عملها تقدم خدماتها للناس ستعمل
الحكومه ما وسعها لتحقيق الامن لاستدباب
الامن لعوده الاوضاع الى طبيعتها وهذه
مهمتها والشعب السوداني سيسال الحكومه
السودانيه من هذه الامور لن يسال طرف اخر
لن يسال المستهيل المساهلين وانما سيسال
الحكومه السودانيه عن لماذا لم توفر لنا
الامن لماذا لم توفي اليونان للاستقلال
لماذا لم تحمينا الحكومه السودانيه هذه
مهمه ومسؤوليه الحكومه السودانيه ومسؤوليه
اي حكومه فيها في في عالمنا هذا هل سيبقى
الموقف موقفكم على حاله حتى مع التلويح من
قبل واشنطن بان هذه الاجراءات اجراءات
العقوبات هي اجراءات تصاعديه مع ما يجري
في الارض
نحن نحن نحب ان تكون اجراءات اجراءات
التصاعديه تتصاعد لالزام الطرف الذي لا
يلتزم بتنفيذ فائليه اخي عبد الصمد نحن
نقول ان القوات المسلحه السودانيه الحكومه
السودانيه تنفذ ما وقعت عليه اذا نفذ
الطرف الاخر ما وقع عليه تعود الحكومه
السودانيه
يعني
اتجاهين ليس اتجاه واحد
فتعليق المفاوضات من طرف الحكومه تعليق
مشروط بان يلتزم الطرف الاخر بهذه الهدنه
ببنود هذه الهدنه اما ان توقع اتفاقيه
ببنود
ولا يلتزم بها الطرفان ثم يقال ان هذه
هدنه هذه ليست هدنه هذا هذا هذا الزام طرف
وغض الطرف عن الطرف عن عن الجانب الاخر
نود ان نرى هدنه يلتزم بها الطرفان ونود
ان نرى ذلك الان وليس غدا او بعد غدا او
بعد حتى بعد ساعه ان التزم الطرف الاخر
ستلتزم الحكومه سيلتزم الجيش السوداني
بالهدنه وهذا ما نعمل ما نامل فيه ونتمناه
شكرا لك منا واشنطن سفيره سوداني لدى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه محمد عبد الله
ادريس لاستقبل الان ضيفي من البيت الابيض
جون كيردي منسق الاتصالات في مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي سيد جوكر باهلا بك هل لكم
ان تشرحوا لنا عن كيف اتخذتم هذا القرار
هذه العقوبات وكيف من شانها ان تساهم في
اتجاه العمل الدبلوماسي التي تقومون به
الامر لا يختصر على العقوبات كان هنالك
ثلاثه اجزاء من العقوبات عقوبات اقتصاديه
على فرضت على اربع شركات اثنان منها
يقوماني بدعم قوات الدعم السريع والاثنين
بدعمي الجيش السوداني لكن قمنا بوضع بعض
القيود على تاشيرات السفر على بعض الافراد
وقمنا ايضا بتحديث الارشادات الخاصه
بالسفر لمعرفه الاعلام المواطنين
الامريكيين بالتحديات التي قد تواجههم كان
عده اجراءات تم اتخاذها فيما يتعلق
بالعقوبات قمنا باستهدافي جهات كما قلت
تدعم الطرفين لانه نعتقد ان من المهم جدا
ان يتم محاسبتهما وان يكون مسؤولين عن سفك
الدماء والعنف والرفض في ان يكون ذلك
التزامه بوقف لاطلاق دارهم يقومون بالحاق
الاذى بالشعب السوداني
ايضا من اجل ان نوضح ان هنالك توقع من قبل
الولايات المتحده ومن المجتمع المدني من
المجتمع الدولي من الطرفاني لكي يجلسان
بشكل جدي في جده وان يحاول التوصل الى
طريق ليس فقط الى وقت لاطلاق النار
بامكانه ان يستمر لكن الى الانتقال الى
الحكم المدني وهذا ما يريده الشعب
السوداني هناك من يشكك في جدوى وتاثير هذه
العقوبات هناك اطراف خارجيه قد تعوض ان
كان هناك نقص نتيجه هذه العقوبات ما يتعلق
بتزويد طرفي الصراع بالسلاح وبالتالي
لماذا فرضت العقوبات فقط على الطرفين ولم
تشمل الاطراف الخارجيه
اتخذنا هذه الاجراءات ضد شركات وهيئات
مرتبطه بشكل كبير في مساله تجهيز الاسلحه
وذخيره للطرفين المتقاتلين اذا نظرنا الى
القائمه هذه منظمات هي تجعل من الطرفين
وتسهل الطرفين تسليحه انفسهما وبالتالي
الحاق الاذى بالشعب السوداني والاستمرار
بسفك الدماء قمنا ايضا بدراسه الكثير من
الخيارات هذه قرارات اتخذناها اليوم هي
ليست نهايه المطاف ولكننا سنبقي الخيارات
منفتحه امامنا نحن لن نستسلم عن امكانيه
وايجاد حل دبلوماسيه من اجل تشجيع الطرفين
للذهاب الى عوده الى جده وجلوس مع بعضهم
البعض على طاوله المفاوضات والقاء الاسلحه
والعمل نحو الانتقال السلمي هذه هي
الاجراءات التي اتخذناها الام ونحن نستمر
وسنعمل على هذا الهدف نسيت ربما استمعت
معنا قبل قليل الى لقائنا مع سفير السودان
لدى واشنطن مستنكرا ومستغربا هذه المساواه
في العقوبات بين طرفين بين كما يقول طرف
شرعي وطرف متمرد وبالتالي كيف تنظر واشنطن
للطرفين حتى فرضت العقوبات بهذا الشكل
المتساوي بين الطرفين
بوسه الطرفين ما يزالان يتقاتلان وكلاهما
يقتلان
السودانيين الابرياء وكلا الطرفين ما يزال
يرتكبان الفضائع ضد النساء والفتيات
السودانيات وكلا الطرفين لا يعملان بجهد
من اجل توصل الى وقف لاطلاق النار وكيل
الطرفين ايضا لا يعملان بجهد كافي من اجل
رؤيه السودان العوده الى السلطه المدنيه
وهذا ما يريده الشعب السوداني بالتالي نحن
سنستمر كما قلت بابقاء الخيارات امامنا
مفتوحه نريد ان نرى حلا سلميا لكن علينا
ان نبدا بالقاء الاسلحه اذا ما نظرت الى
المؤسسات والهيئات التي تم فرض العقوبات
عليها نحن نامل انها ستساعد في تحقيق هذه
النتيجه نامل ان الجنرال الحميتي جنرال
برهان سيراني هذا الامر وسيفهماني
في مساله مسالتهما والاهم من ذلك نحن
جديون جدا في مساله رؤيه عوده السلام
والاستقرار الى السودان هل تنظران الى
الطرفين على قدم المساواه الجيش هو الجيش
ويصف الطرف الاخر بانه جهه متمرده سياسيا
كيف تقيم وتنظر واشنطن للطرفين من حيث
التسميه والشرعيه
يتم ارتكابه من كلا القوات المسلحه
السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع وهو امر غير
ضروري على الاطلاق
قاموا
بزياده هذه العداوه بينهما بطريقه قام زاد
فيها ارتكاب الفضاء وسفك الدماء في انحاء
السودان والملايين الاشخاص لا يستطيعون
الحصول على الغذاء والماء والرعايه الصحيه
بسبب هذا الصراع والقتال بالتالي من المهم
جدا نحن الى جانب الشعب السوداني ومن
المهم جدا ان يكون لديهم الامان
والاستقرار الذي يستحقونه ومن كانه الوصول
الى الغذاء والماء والرعايه الصحيه هم
يستحقون هذا الامر ويحتاجونه بشده بالتالي
نحن نريد من هؤلاء القاده ان يكونوا في
نفس الموقف ايضا هل تقيم الوضع واشنط ن
للوضع في السودان لانها امام طرفين شرعيين
يتقاتلون وبالتالي تحاسبهما على هذا
القتال ام لها مقاربه مختلفه
اعتقد ان اجراءاتنا تتحدث بوضوح حول كيفيه
نظرنا الى هذا الصراع وكما ذكرته سابقا
نحن نقف الى جانب الشعب السوداني نحن نقف
الى جانب الدعم والاستقرار والسلام في
الشعب السوداني نريد ان تحترم تحترم حقوق
الشعب السوداني وحاليا لا يتم احترام هذه
الحقوق من اي من الطرفين من البيت الابيض
هي منسقه الاتصالات في مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
هذا وقال الرئيس الامريكي
لا تسعى الى صراع مع بيجين لكنها ستقف الى
جانبي اصدقائها واضاف ان الولايات المتحده
تعزز امنها في منطقه المحيطين الهندي
والهادى وتعمل مع شركائها لمواجهه ما وصفه
بتهديدات كوريا الشماليه
من جهتها احتجت بيجين على توقيع واشنطن
اتفاقات تجاريه مع تايوان وقالت ان
التعاون العسكري بين واشنطن وطوكي يجب ان
لا يضر بمصالح طرف ثالث
[موسيقى]
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها قامت
بتصفيه اكثر من 50 بقاتلا اوكرانيا على
المنطقه الحدوديه بين بيل جرود واوكرانيا
صباح اليوم الخميس خلال هجوم مسلح بدبابات
ومركبات مدرعه استهدف المدينه ياتي ذلك في
وقت ظلت فيه بالقرود المدينه الحدوديه على
راس التطورات الابرز في الحرب منذ اسابيع
لكن جبهات عديده كانت بدورها مسرحا
للمواجهات جنوبا او شرقا وظلت العاصمه ضمن
بنك اهداف موسكو مع تعرضها لقصف بصواريخ
اسكندر الروسيه
بالبرود الروسيه على تخوم خار كيف
الاوكرانيات في صداره التطورات منذ اسابيع
كانت في بدايه الحرب مركزا لوجستيان
ومنطلقا لمهاجمه روسيا لخركيب وايزيوم
والتقدم شرقا
[موسيقى]
بالمقابل تحدث حاكم خركيبه الاوكرانيه عن
تكثيف القوات الروسيه من هجماتها على
القرى الحدوديه مع بيلود حيث استهدف القصف
المنطقه الصناعيه فيها واعلن احباط توغري
من سماها مجموعات استخباراتيه روسيه كانت
تحاول استكشاف الدفاعات الاوكرانيه في
بدت التطورات وفق خبراء عسكريين رساله
ارباح اوكرانيه وفعلا تكتيكيا لخدمه هدف
استراتيجي اوكراني من خلال اسقاط المنظومه
الدفاعيه الروسيه وتثبيت العديد من قوتها
في مناطق وجبهات معينه وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تحدثت ايضا عن احتدام القتال على
محوريكا في مقاطعه دونيتسك واستهداف
القوات الاوكرانيه في عدد من المناطق
مشيره الى مقتل نحو 400 جندي اوكراني لكن
في بخموت شرقي البلاد محاوله اوكرانيه
لمهاجمتها من الاجنحه حيث بث قائد القوات
البريه الاوكرانيه تسجيلا مصورا يظهر مقال
انه استمرار قصف قواته واقعه مركز روسي
فيها وعلى جبهه اخرى قال المتحرك باسم قوه
الشرق الاوكرانيه ان قواته تصدت لجميع
المحاولات الروسيه بالتقدم على محور
الايمان كوبيانسك شرقي البلاد خرسون
المقاطعه الجنوبيه بدورها تعرضت لقصف روسي
شمل معظم اراضي المقاطعه ولم تسلم منه
ايضا كل من ميكولايفولوجيا شمالا اسرع
اعتياديا اعلان حاله التاهب الجوي القصوى
في العاصمه كييف ومناطق الشماليه البلاد
حيث تحدثت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه عن
اسقاط الدفاعاتها لعشره صواريخ باليستيه
روسيه من طراز اسكندر وفي حين سرع الرئيس
الاوكراني
لتجديد مطالبته بتعزيز الدفاعات بلاده
الجويه اعلن البنتاجون وفي احدث التصريحات
ان المساعدات الامريكيه الجديده
تتضمن انظمه ستينجر المضاده للطائرات
وذخائر اضافيه لنظامي باتريوت وهيمارس
[موسيقى]
هذا وجدد الرئيس الاوكراني دعوته العاجله
للانضمام بلاده الى الاتحاد الاوروبي وحلف
شمال الاطلسي في اقرب وقت ممكن وحذر في
كلمه امام المشاركين في قمه المجموعه
السياسيه الاوروبيه
من حرب مفتوحه او زحف روسي في حال رفض
الانضمام وتزامنت القمه الاوروبيه مع
اجتماع وزراء خارجيه حلف شمال الاطلسي
باوسلو لبحث تسويات بشان انضمام اوكرانيا
للحلف واختيار بديل للامين العام الحالي
وكذلك النفقات العسكريه
من اختيار المكان الى عدد الحاضرين رسائل
الاتحاد الاوروبي المتحديه لروسيا والرئيس
بوتين لا تتوقف في حرب عسكريه ودبلوماسيه
تبدو طويله الصوره الجماعيه لا تعني ان كل
من فيها يجمعنا على انضمام اوكرانيا الى
اسره الاتحاد الاوروبي وحلف شمال الاطلس
قريبا كما تشاء كييف عنوان القمه المجموعه
السياسيه الاوروبيه حضرها ما لا يقل عن
خمسين من القاده الاوروبيين الاعضاء وغير
الاعضاء في الاتحاد وابرز المشاركين
الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي الذي حضر شخصيا
الى بلده بول بواكل مولدافيا مكان انعقاد
القمه تبعد 20 كيلومتر فقط عن اوكرانيا
خلال كلمته اوضح الرئيس زيلينسكي ان عدم
منح العضويه الكامله في الاتحاد وحلف
النيتو لن يكون له سوى بديلين هما اما حرب
مفتوحه او احتلال روسي زاحف الرضاعه
علينا ان نتذكر ان كل شك نظهره هو خندق
ستحاول روسيا احتلاله وكل شك يجلب المزيد
من انعدام الامان
كلامهم موجه للمعترضين او الداعين الى
تاجيل منح كييف العضويه لاسباب سياسيه
تختلف من برلين الى واشنطن مرورا
والكلام عن الدعم غير المسبوق والمستمر
وحده غير كاف
الذي يطالب بضمانات امنيه بعد انتهاء
الحرب لم يصله من اسلوب ما يثلج صدره
ثلاثه ملفات متشابكه وشائكه كانت على جدول
اعمال وزراء خارجيه حلف شمال الاطلس في
اجتماع البحث عن تسويات بشان انضمام
اوكرانيا خلافه الامين العام الحالي
والنفقات العسكريه البحث عن تسويات يعني
وجود انقسامات حتى وان عمل الامين العام
على اظهار الوجه المشرقي للحلف والله
العظيم
كل اعضاء الحلف متفقون على ان ابواب
الناتو مفتوحه لعضويه دول جديده وكل
الاعضاء متفقون على ان اوكرانيا ستصبح
عضوا في الحلف وهذا قرار تتخذه الدول
الاعضاء وليست موسكو هي من يرفض او يقبل
توسع النيتو
ليس كل الاعضاء على وفاق بشان تسريع عمليه
الانضمام وخاصه في اوجه الصراع العسكري
المتحفظون على تحديد جدول زمني وخريطه
طريق واضحه كما يطالب زيلينسكي بالحاح
يخشون من تفعيل الماده الخامسه من ميثاق
النيتو في اليوم الاول من انضمامها ما
يعني دخول كل الاعضاء في حرب مباشره مع
موسكو وهذا ما لا تتمناه وعشره وبرلين
غياب تسويه في اوسلو يعني احتدام النقاشات
في قمه فيلينيوس المقرره في يوليو المقبل
كثره التجمعات حلفاء كييف بالنسبه الى
روسيا معركه دبلوماسيه اخرى مع الغرب الذي
يعمل على حصلها واضعافها نددت موسكو
بالاطراف الداعمه في الحرب الدائره اذ قال
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي الروسي
ان الارهاب وصف ينطبق على نظام كييف ومن
يقف وراءه وخاصه الامريكيين والا ربيين
الذين اختاروا طريق الحرب ضدنا على حد
تعبيره من بيلجورود الى كييف تاخذ المعارك
منعطفات جديده لا تغير شيئا في حقيقه ان
الحرب ابعد من ان تضع اوزارها قريبا
بالرغم من تكلفتها الباهضه السياسيا
وعسكريا على من في اوروبا وخارجها وعلى
اعضاء وغير اعضائي الاتحاد الاوروبي وحلف
النيتو
قال الرئيس صربي الكسندر في تصريح للجزيره
ان الاوضاع في شمال كوسوفو تتطلب جهودا
كبيره لخفض التصعيد واكد في مؤتمر صحفي
على هامش القمه السياسيه الاوروبيه في
مولدوفا ان المنطقه برمتها تحتاج الى
السلم والهدوء والاستقرار
ما اعرف انه يجب بذل جهود كبيره لخفض
التصعيد لذا تبحثنا بشان هذا الموضوع في
نهايه الجلسه العامه مع كل القاده نحتاج
الى خفض التصعيد من اجل السلم والهدوء
والاستقرار في كل المنطقه وامل ان نجد
حلولا سالتقي بالرئيس الفرنسي والمستشار
الالماني وبوريل واتمنى ان تكون لديهم
افكار للحل
[تصفيق]
يتظاهر مئات او الوف الاشخاص من الاقليه
الصربيه في اطراف دوله صغيره نسبيه اسمها
كوسوفو فتهتز منطقه البلقان كلها او تكاد
على وقع هتافات الاحقاد العرقيه المتعاليه
علنا ويضع ملايين الاوروبيين ايديهم على
قلوبهم خشيه تفجر نزاع عسكري جديد في
قاراته بعد 15 شهرا من اندلاع الحرب
الروسيه المستمره لا تزال على اوكرانيا
السبب المعلن للتوتر في الجمهوريه الواقعه
جنوب شرقي اوروبا كان ابسط من ان يثير
المخاوف التي اثارها واقل من ان تشخص اليه
انظار القوى الكبرى في العالم لولا ان
وراء الاكمه ما وراءها من اسباب يتجلى
المحلي والاقليمي منها في ذاكره تفيض
بالمذابح الجماعيه بينما يمتد دولي على
خارطه تصل حتى الى موسكو وواشن
هي اسماء بلدات في شمال كوسوفو بدا ذكرها
يتكرر في صداره نشرات الاخبار خلال الايام
القليله الماضيه بعدما جاءت الانباء منها
لتقول ان الاقليه الصربيه التي تشكل
الغالبيه السكانيه في هذه المنطقه قاطعت
الانتخابات البلديه الشهر الماضي ثم حين
فاز ممثلون الاكثريه الالبانيه خرجت بقضها
وقضيضها الى الشوارع لمنع رؤساء البلديات
المنتخبين من تولي مهامهم وهو ما ادى الى
اندلاع مواجهات لم تتوقف منذ نحو اسبوعا
بين المتظاهرين من جهه وقوات الشرطه
ووحدات حلف الناتو المرابطه هناك من جهه
اخرى
لكن القصه بصيغتها تلك تظلنا قصه كثيرا او
هي تحتاج حتى تكتمل الى رؤيه اشباح الماضي
الدموي وقد بدات تتملل اخيرا لكان العقود
ثلاثه الماضيه لم تغير شيئا في النفوس
البشريه للسكان المتناحرين ولا في
الحسابات الجيوسيه للقوى المتصارعه على
الهيمنه والنفوذ تقع عاصمتها برشتينا جنوب
شرقي اوروبا وتصل مساحتها الى عشره الاف
وتسعمائه كيلو متر مربع تقريبا اما عدد
سكانها فيبلغ نحو مليون
وثمانمات اكثريتهم الساحقه من الالبان
بينما تشكل الاقليات الصربيه نحو سته في
المئه وهؤلاء يتركزون اساسا في المناطق
المجاوره لصربيا ويحظون بدعمها الى حد عبر
عن نفسه اخيرا باعلان الرئيس الصربي
الكسندر وضع جيشها في حال تاخ د فضلا عن
اصداره اوامر بتحرك وحدات عسكريه نحو
الحدود بين البلدين
تلك هي الجغرافيا اما التاريخ او تاريخ
القريب ففيه ما يفسر وينذر هنا وقعت قبل
نحو ربع قرن حرب شاواء بين القوات الصربيه
واليوغوسلافيه من جهه وجبهه تحرير كوسوفو
التي تشكلت من الاكثريه الالبانيه بزعامه
ابراهيم روجوفا من جهه اخرى كانت صربيا في
عهد رئيسها الذي حكم لاحقا بتهمه ارتكاب
جرائم ضد الانسانيه
ترى في كوسوفو ذات الاكثريه المسلمه مكانا
مقدسا للصرب نظرا لوجود مقر الكنيسه
الارثوذكسيه على ارضها ولذلك قمعت
احتياجاتها المناديه بالاستقلال بدءا من
عام
1989 ثم شنت ضدها حمله عسكريه تخللتها
مذابح جماعيه وتطهير عرقي لم ينتهيا الا
بعد تدخل عسكري من حلف الناتو تغير العالم
من بعد او هكذا بدل امر في مستهل الالفيات
الثالثه غير ان تطور الاحداث ظل يكشف عن
بقاء الضغائن ومعها حسابات المصالح تفعل
فعلها في حظر المنطقه ومستقبلها رفضت
صربيا الاعتراف باستقلال كوسوفو عام 2008
ومثلها فعلت روسيا ثم ها هو الكرملين يعلن
تاييده لصربي كوسوفو في مقابل تمديد البيت
الابيض وحلفائه بسلوك حليفاتهم حكومه
برشتينا ثم مبادرتهم بارسال المئات من
جنود الناتو الى هناك من يريد نزاعا
عسكريا ثانيا في اوروبا ذلك هو السؤال
الان وفي محاولات الجواب عليه يتفرع
السؤال ايضا عما اذا كان كل ذلك يشكل
تهديدا جديدا بنشوب الحرب او هو مجرد ضغوط
لانهاء سابقتها التي ما زالت في اوكرانيا
تستعر وتصلي بنارها شعوبا كثيره في الشمال
الغني كما في الجنوب الفقير
قبل الحصات كنت قد اجريت مقابله مع جنرال
انجيلو ميتشلي ريستوشيا قائد قوه حفظ
السلام التابعه للنيتو في كوسوفو وسالته
عن الوضع الميداني في شمال كوسوفو
الوضع
خطر جدا ومتقلب فقط فقد احداث السابقه
تشهد الماده خطوره الوضع وحتى اي
حادث يمكن يؤدي الى تصعيد وبالتالي الا
اذا قامتان
بالتوصل الى حل يعيد بهما الى مائده
المفاوضات لتطبيق الاتفاق الذي جرى التوصل
اليه
في السابق بعد بعد اجتماعات بروكسل
والا فان الوضع سوف يزداد تدهورا هل لديكم
النيه لزياده عدد القوات
الامين العام للنيتو فعلا قدم تصريحا وذكر
بان قوات جديده سوف تاتي الى مسرح
العمليات هل اتصلتم بالطرفين لمحاوله
التهدئه
انا في التواصل مستمر مع جميع اطراء اصحاب
العلاقه مع مع كل الاطراف وطبعا مع كل من
يهمه الامر ويود
ان ياتي بالاستقرار والسلام للمنطقه وانا
نيتي واسمع ان اواصل دائما فتحه قناه
مفتوحه لتسهيل العمل على الارض من اجل خلق
الظروف اللازمه على الارض
لفتح المجال للمفاوضات لتنجح وايضا كما
قلت سابقا للاتيان بالجانبين الى مائده
المفاوضات ماذا طلبتم من الطرفين سواء من
بريشنا او من صربيا
هذا يبدو بسيطا جدا القول ذلك ولكن صعب
جدا في الممارسه العمليه ان تتحدث الى
الطرفين ان يتبادل الثقه فيما بينهما ان
يتبادلها كل ما حصل لحد الان
يقوموا
وتخلي عن اراء سابقه اذا ما وثقه بشكل
اكبر بين بين بعضهما فاعتقد ان الموقف
يتطور ايجابيا
لمحاوله التوصل الى خلق جوا ايجابيا جنرال
موسكو دخلت على الخط ووصفت قواتكم بانها
تؤدي الى مزيد من التصعيد ما تعليقكم
لا تعلم ما الذي يحصل نحن كنا هناك على
الارض نحن نحن لعبنا دورا كبيرا في
الافخاء الوضع قابل للسيطره ومنعت تطوره
وتصعيده لولا تدخلنا
لتساعد الوضع بطريقه بحيث ان الطرفين ما
ما كان يستطعان السيطره عليه
وكان ذلك سيؤدي الى ماساه باعتقادك هذا
التعليق وهذا الموقف من موسكو هل له تاثير
تفضل تفضل
قلت باننا
عملنا على التطبيق ولايتنا وصلاحياتنا
وعملنا في
المعايير والمجال الذي حددته مركز قرار
مجلس الامن
الذي صدر فيها عام 19
وعملنا بيوجب قواعد الاشتباك مع احترام
كامل لكل قواعد والعمل والقوانين الدوليه
طيب فيما يتعلق بسؤال عن تصريحات موسكو
وموقفها المعلم بانكم تشكلون قوه تصعيد
للوضع فيما يتعلق بكوسوفو هل لهذا التصريح
تاثير هذا الموقف من قبل موسكو
نحن اقرر مره اخرى نحن نخلق ظروف لكي لا
يتدهور الوضع دون تدخلنا
لخالته الوضع الى درجه بعد ان جانبين كان
يفقدان السيطره على على بعضهما وعلى طرف
الاخر
نحن قمنا بدور كبير ومهم لتجنب مثل هذا
الوضع الكبير اذا تدهور الوضع لا قدر الله
جنرال انجيلو ما سيكون موقفكم
نحن فقط نطبق ولايتنا وصلاحيات الممنوحه
لنا نحن مستعدون لمواجهه اي وضع يحصل
بتطبيق ولايتنا ونحن هنا المساهمه في
المحافظه على تامين وضع امن وسالم ولجميع
من يعيش في كوزوفو
افادت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه نواشنطن
باشرت يوم الخميس حسب اشعاراتي معاهده
ستارت الجديده عن روسيا بما في ذلك مواقع
الصواريخ والقذفات واضفت الخارجيه في بيان
ان الولايات المتحده اوقفت مشاركه بيانات
القياس عن بعد مع روسيا بشان عمليه اطلاق
الصواريخ البالستيه من الغواصات واكدت
الخارجيه ان واشنطن اتخذت تلك الخطوات ردا
على انتهاكات موسكو المستمره لمعاهده
ستارت الجديده مشيره في الوقت ذاته الى ان
واشنطن ملتزمه بالتنفيذ الكامل والمتبادل
للمعاهده
قال رئيسه تونسي قيس سعيد انه لا مجال لاي
وزير بالتصرف خارج السياسه التي يقرها
رئيس الجمهوريه وفق قوله مضيفا ان
الانسجامه مطلوب بين كافه اعضاء الحكومه
فلما جابه ان يتصرف اي وزير
خارج السياسه التي يضبطها رئيس الجمهوريه
فالانسجام مطلوب
بدنا نصل الى ختام حصاد هذه الليله والذي
كان نصيب الاوفر له فيما يتعلق بالملف
السوداني وتطوراتي خاصه الاثراء العقوبات
المفروضه امريكيه وكذلك تعليق المحادثات
في جده الان الى الجزيره منتصف الليل رفقه
عبد السلام وسيله